so you're telling me that there was a
black super soldier having to remember
this guy's name when all i can recall is
his alias
what if they're going to repeat scenes
we can't repeat sins
why'd you give up that shield i'm going
to be waking up in the middle of the
night screaming why'd you give up that
shield for the next year
after hearing it so many times on the
show why does this even need to be in
the previously on segment we know that
will be said at least once during the
actual episode super soldiers sure do
run a lot but
why having the super serum running
through your body means you don't have
to run or really perform any kind of
exercise you can just eat tater tots and
donuts all day while watching hot and
cleveland marathons on tv land why are
you [ __ ] running john
why if walker is struggling with a
flashback wouldn't he be seeing it
through his own eyes
i mean i don't really want to see first
person perspective of this guy getting
his head smashed by cap and face crunch
but it would at least be accurate
also thank you show the flashback was in
the previously on one minute ago and we
could all
really use a break from being bashed
over the head by the scene
this is like watching a bird fly into a
window over and over again
try something else that works why remove
protective gear in the middle of a
choking out of your opponent
the few seconds it would take to unclasp
the chin strap would have given sam the
advantage
so if america here rips off sam's wings
which in addition to creating an excuse
for a new suit
also somehow renders him unconscious
great oh
so bucky does know how to hit something
other than the massive bullseye right in
front of him
maybe hold on to that until captain
america has been retained by the
authorities or
sam at least has a chance to catch his
breath and stand up she's going
we'll never find her but only because
we're told so if they want to find
anyone else on the planet they just pack
a cell phone or enhance a satellite or
phone in wakanda
she winds up in new york by the end of
the episode so surely they'd be able to
track
oh i don't know planes captain america
killing a
foreign national in public it's kind of
like a big deal like like
international incident big i agree
which is why i don't understand how sam
still has the shield that is a [ __ ]
murder weapon
that should be in evidence who even
allowed that to be cleaned also this
episode ruins my sin from last episode
about not being able to get the stain
out of the shield
and i'm petty so these chairs are off
limits but this microwave and oven are
okay guys
wait yo you forgot the wings cable
and somehow sam has the authority to
give away the tech to torres
for reasons also remember torres
consider yourself extremely fortunate mr
walker
and return the shield to us with
expedience how do they not know that sam
has the shield
torrez and many other officers were at
the earlier grc operation and saw sam
walk off with it
ah yes when i'm approached by a strange
woman clomping towards me my instinct is
to look at her shoes rather than her
face
you know because identifying someone's
footwear is incredibly useful
valentina allegra defontaine awesome
this reveal means we might be
one step closer to a thunderbolts movie
or tv series but as i learned from
wandavision this is most likely just a
teasing not something we'll see resolved
on this series
marvel could have benefited from the
teachings of the great german scholars
the scorpions the mtu knows how to tease
me but i'm not sure they know how to
please me this show really wants us to
believe that carly is an intelligent
person who's able to evade the
government with no issues but then there
are scenes like this
where she returns to the scene of a grc
takeover and that is not what a smart
person that knows how to avoid her enemy
would do she might send some of her
people to do it but she'd never show her
face there again
also why did the grc decide not to watch
these locations in case carly and the
crew showed up they just threw up some
caution tape and flyers and shrugged
their shoulders like well guess we can
all go home for the day because
obviously carly's hiding somewhere we'd
never find her
littering
[Music]
what do you suppose the conversation
between bucky and the dora malay was
like hey i'm gonna trick zemo into
thinking i'm going to kill him with a
bullet to the face so you all wait over
there out of sight until you see him
his pants and then walk dramatically
over so that he actually shuts his pants
when his face sinks in
we will take him to the raft well glad
that all wrapped up so nice and tidy for
bucky and i understand the grc has their
hands full with the captain america they
appointed being a power-hungry loony
bird but are sam and bucky really not
going to be in any kind of trouble for
breaking zemo out of prison i mean
that's a federal offense
hey paying ao watering plants at night
what i think it is a deflated mastodon
testicle yes
yes it is also let's go ahead and stir
up a lot of pain and bad memories for
this poor guy again that was so much fun
the first time around
they will never let a black man
be captain america and even if they did
no
self-respecting black man would ever
want to be there is so much truth in
this bit of dialogue and while the show
often struggles with presenting moral
complexities this is perfect it almost
makes me want to take all the sins back
for complaining about why didn't you
keep the shield talk
i said almost but i'll at least give one
back for this amazing moment
sarah i'm coming home and i'll just
immediately hang up on you after my
exclamation nothing cryptic or weird
about that way to potentially freak your
sister out for no reason sam
in about 10 years we'll have this thing
fixed
it also feels like the sam goes back
home and fixes the boat sequence takes
10 years but you don't hear me
complaining
you know except for right now and the
entirety of this video
bennett and elling's dad cannot get up
before noon
kids keep showing up hungry but are too
proud to ask for any help and you're
just like mom feeding every kid in the
neighborhood
and luckily sam was present for the
handing off lunch portion of the day so
he could realize the way he's going to
save the boat and his family which leads
to a revelation about what it means to
take up the shield and become the next
captain america
i mean what if he'd slept in how do we
get it off the truck
no but seriously if bucky hadn't
randomly been there how would they have
gotten it off the truck
i'm in fixing together the only way to
work out pointless grudges since 1817.
i'm lucky flirting with your friend's
sister if they don't add an l
here at some point i will send this show
a hundred times this is just a sin to
remind me to do that because if i don't
sin i forget
she's a very mean person
sam and bucky are kicked off of boat
fixing duty and walk away bantering back
and forth for a few seconds
great fine but at least let us hear what
they're saying rather than force us to
turn on closed captions to read their
conversation over the swelling music
sam is a dick to trees also if the
shield got stuck in the tree when it was
thrown how is it not destroying this
padding or falcon's fingers
steve told me what he was planning i
don't think either of us really
understood what it felt like for
a black man to be handed the shield are
you an apology
i'm sorry so when you retired it it
made me feel like i had nothing left
well look at that
bucky's doing some deep inner healing
suppose we shouldn't be surprised now
that he's no longer seeing that terrible
therapist and yes
she deserves yet another sin this is our
history we can't lose this fight
my goodness there's more reflecting in
this episode than a fun house full of
mirrors
this training montage does not contain a
survivor song so
sam's just hanging out training back
home with captain america shield and
no one is coming for it i swear to steve
this episode is shot after shot of
shield porn it's at least 68
shield porn so with no money and barely
any resources how is carly managing the
technical infrastructure to lead a
rebellion
everyone in the park hears this why does
new york get a title card but earlier
washington didn't be consistent show we
could have send you for making obvious
title cards
twice show ends on 15 seconds of sam
staring at something we can't see
which in addition to being a dick move
will also be a huge disappointment when
it's revealed next week it's actually
full of receipts and expense forms that
have to be organized for falcons taxes
oh that's not right he is gone
he's gone from here the evil is gone
we could have been a team i could have
been a contender
i'm batman this is what happened when
your life is at stake
you do anything by any means necessary
it is a mandate you don't want the truth
because deep down in places you don't
talk about at parties
you want me on that wall you need me on
that wall
yeah and when i see priests in the
street i never ever stare at him and yet
i'm careful not to look away see because
i want to make the freaks feel
comfortable
it's my boat you have to consider the
optics
the optics are whatever we show we have
to believe in what we're doing to
support us
gentlemen you can't fight in here this
is the war room